bonjour à tous
vous pouvez regagner vos places la
matinée va continuer cette année nous
allons beaucoup parlé d'europe parce que
l'europe c'est notre héritage et c'est
notre horizon parce que la construction
européenne est au coeur du projet
démocrate et parce qu'en 2022 nous avons
un rendez vous majeur qui est la
présidence française de l'union
européenne
et c'est la raison pour laquelle au
printemps dernier nous avons constitué
un groupe de travail rassemblant le
modem et le parti démocrate européen
rassemblant des parlementaires européens
les parlementaires des élus locaux des
adhérents du modem et nous dévoilons
aujourd'hui le fruit de leur travail je
veux les remercier beaucoup dit avoir
contribué vous allez entendre un certain
nombre d'entre eux dans quelques minutes
le fruit de ce travail
ce sont douze propositions pour la
présidence française de l'union
européenne que nous avons rassemblés
dans un livre blanc que nous publions
aujourd'hui est le fruit de ce travail
ce sont aussi des témoignages des
témoignages de nos ministres de nos
parlementaires de nos élus sur leur
sentiment d'appartenance à l'union
européenne et sur leur histoire
personnelle avec l'europe je vous laisse
les découvrir en images
je suis européen je suis français et je
pense que je suis l'un et l'autre
depuis toujours je me suis sentie
européenne pour la première fois à l'âge
de 10 ans quand j'ai vu le mur de berlin
s'écroulait s'effondrer avec beaucoup
d'émotion je voyais des gens se
retrouver et je me suis dit que
finalement l'union européenne c'était ça
c'était rassembler les peuples la
première fois que le suspect européen
c'est le moment où je suis rendu compte
qu'il n'y avait pas que la france dans
le monde le jour je me suis sentie
européenne pour la première fois j'étais
très jeune sur la grand place de béthune
au pied du beffroi il y avait un
festival folklorique européen je me suis
dit l'europe c'est magnifique c'est la
couleur c'est la diversité c'est des
chants des danses quand j'étais enfant
en fait j'ai eu la chance d'habiter en
région frontalière je suis à 15
kilomètres de la suisse à 40 km de
l'allemagne et là je me suis dit tiens à
deux pas de chez moi il ya des gens qui
sont pas exactement pareil que moi
j'habite à cracovie donc moi l'europe
c'est tous les jours c'est les conflits
européens c'est dans la famille
finalement ce serait peut-être pas si
bête que ça de pouvoir s'entendre les
moments qui a frappé ma vie a frappé
toutes les générations c'étaient les 9
novembre 1989 la télévision italienne
nous annonce que les murs de berlin est
avait chuté j'ai compris qu'il y avait
quelque chose d'énorme qui était en
train de se passer pour les européens et
pour le monde entier donc j'ai commencé
à appeler au téléphone mes amis on a
près une voiture et on est allé à berlin
tout juste après la chute du mur et j'ai
quoi que ça c'est un moment que je
n'oublierai jamais qui a fait partir de
mon engagement en tant que citoyen est
aujourd'hui en tant que personnes
engagées en politique le sentiment
d'être européenne je lui extrêmement
fortement tu serais tu es mon premier
vote la première fois qu'on a voté en
1979 pour le parlement européen donc je
ne pouvais pas imaginer
plus beau projet pour me sentir
européenne pas pour moi le sentiment
européen il est né relativement tôt elle
est assise naturelle
puisque je suis vraiment né en allemagne
de parents allemands mais qu'il n'ait
délégation allemande une formation
allemande et aujourd'hui je suis députée
française à l'assemblée nationale quand
je suis arrivé en france est à 38 ans ça
n'aura pas pu être possible dans ma
tendre enfance
il y avait une cérémonie qui compte
énormément c'est d'aller au monument aux
morts le 11 novembre mon grand père
était est et est mort à la guerre 14 et
mon père m'a dit plus jamais ça
alors à ce moment là vous comprenez
pourquoi parce que ça touche votre
famille et quand vous voyez sur la
colonne de votre village
tous les membres des familles des
voisins que le connaissent et qui sont
morts ou dit plus jamais ça nous avons
beaucoup beaucoup de lieux de mémoire
aussi dans l'union européenne et de
temps en temps il faudrait qu'on se
rappelle d'où on vient quel chemin en
fait on a parcouru je crois qu'il faut
qu'on se souvienne qu'est ce que c'est
l'europe c'est pas un traité
international c'est beaucoup beaucoup
plus profond c'est vraiment des ennemis
héréditaires qui ont décidé de vivre
ensemble quand l'histoire avec un grand
h
rencontre l'histoire de votre famille eh
bien c'est la connaissent et de
conviction et l'attachement au projet
européen tel qu'il existe aujourd'hui
j'ai deux petits enfants franco
espagnole alors je le vis vraiment parmi
trip cette europe moi je suis allé
demander la main de ma femme en
septembre 89 en vélo de metz à cracovie
je pensais pas que je raconterai ça
aujourd'hui il y avait encore le rideau
de fer et comme je dis souvent je suis
passé tellement vite que le mur est
tombé puisque le mur est tombé dans les
trois mois après j'aime bien cette
notion de gradient de frontières de
considérer que les frontières seront des
espaces et plus des murs on sent
vraiment repères parce qu'on va passer
des frontières facilement parce qu'on a
eu besoin que de sa carte d'identité
pour aller d'un centre d'être états
membres parce qu'on travaille en ce
moment sur un numéro de sécurité social
européen l'appartenance à l'europe je
les ai toujours ressenti quand j'étais
au lycée on étudié shakespeare j'ai lu
don quichotte quand j'étais aussi
enfants pour moi la culture européenne
c'était le liquide amniotique dans
lequel je me suis formé si je puis dire
mon premier souvenir d'europe il remonte
à 1992
j'avais 9 ans et se tenait le référendum
de maastricht j'ai pris conscience
vaguement que quelque chose de très
important se jouer à l'échelle du
continent mais l'enfant que j'étais a
aussi pris conscience que l'europe
pouvait avoir un effet très important
dans mon quotidien puisqu'on avait
décidé où on allait décider de se doter
d'une monnaie commune alors qu'est ce
que j'ai fait est bien
et
rédigées à la main un petit tracts pour
inciter mes voisins à aller voter j'ai
donc fait quelques photocopies que j'ai
été boire tgt distribué moi même dans
notre quartier c'est donc été mon
premier acte politique un acte européen
l'europe c'est une idée formidable c'est
très simple s'il n'y a pas d'europe
organisés nous disparaissons dans les 20
ans qui viennent si on aime sa ville sa
région son pays si on veut plus de
france il faut plus d'europe si on aime
nos nations si on veut pas qu'elle soit
détruite dans une grande compétition
mondiale qui n'est pas un choix il faut
une mondialisation responsable humaine
et c'est comme ça qu'on arrivera à avoir
une europe aussi forte l'espace européen
nous a conduits à aller plus loin et
plus fort on le voit bien d'ailleurs sur
les questions de transition écologique
on revient sur la question d'égalité des
chances aujourd'hui lorsque je parle
avec mes homologues de différents pays
on s'aperçoit que les problèmes qui nous
concernent se pose de la même manière à
manchester à berlin à paris et arras
soyez vous est donc là ce sentiment
européen c'est de se dire nous avons les
mêmes problèmes nous pouvons avoir les
mêmes solutions
retroussons les manches ensemble et nous
allons pouvoir progresser le
gouvernement aux tendances à mettre leur
propre échec sur le compte de l'europe
moi je me réjouis nous voyons l'europe
comme une chance comme une opportunité
comme un débouché comme un objectif et
pas comme un bouc émissaire si
l'éducation périclite roumanie c'est
notre problème c'est pas le problème des
roumains si la bulgarie n'arrive pas à
absorber les crédits les crédits
européens c'est pas le problème des
bulgares on prépare l'avenir de nos
enfants si on a une europe dans dix ans
qui est extrêmement dynamique mais qui
se concentre entre bordeaux et berlin
n'aura raté a failli je place en premier
plan de toutes nos relations avant les
relations économiques et autres la
relation humaine la relation sociale
pour
maintenir et développer des relations
avec les autres pays si nous voulons
vivre en paix agir ensemble vis-à-vis de
des exigences sociales
éthiques ne se construisent pas
l'intérêt de l'europe des concurrence
économique des concurrences social c'est
un projet humaniste le projet européen
qui est un projet qui combine la
prospérité le respect des droits humains
la volonté de rayonnement des grands
principes qui doivent fonder pour nous
une démocratie l'europe c'est un projet
permanent et ce qui unifie l'histoire de
ce projet permanent c'est cet
attachement à la liberté cet attachement
à l'égalité à la solidarité désormais à
la transition écologique pour faire de
l'union européenne un continent qui est
à l'avant-garde sur tous ces sujets
l'union européenne justement avec ce
projet de paix avec ce projet de liberté
avec ce projet basé sur des valeurs elle
a un rôle capital à jouer sur la scène
internationale pour faire en sorte aussi
que dans un contexte qui est de plus en
plus tendue qui est de plus en plus
difficile sur le plan économique sur le
plan diplomatique sur le plan de la
défense elle arrive à créer les
conditions sur la scène internationale
du vivre ensemble c'est pas pour rien
que autant de gens veulent nous
rejoindre parce qu on a une richesse
énorme ici simplement aujourd'hui il
faut aussi savoir défendre cette
richesse non positionner je pense qu'il
faut jamais perdre de vue le sens de
l'engagement politique pourquoi on le
fait et pour qui on le fait et quand on
perd pas de vue cette ambition là je
crois qu'on y arrive si nous voulons
vivre avec nos valeurs avec nos intérêts
avec notre influence avec ce que nous
sommes ce que nous apportons au monde il
faut absolument s'unir
c'est presque déjà une conclusion de
jean louis bourlanges mesdames messieurs
bonjour à tous chers amis participant de
guidel bienvenue à nos participants de
cette première table ronde que nous
avons voulu consacrer à l'europe vous
savez que l'europe et le modem c'est
quand même une histoire assez ancienne
c'est comme un marqueur extrêmement
important est le fait que nous ayons
cette première table ronde ça veut aussi
dire quelque chose au niveau de nos
valeurs alors on va essayer
pour ne pas faire un entre nous mais de
faire un avec vous on va essayer d'être
extrêmement synthétique on a une demi
heure de retard sur le timing donc on va
essayer d'être je vais pas dire la
synthèse que ça rend vous nous aurons un
autre parti politique mais on va être
dans la concision ben je crois que paul
eluard ne disait il faut parfois peu de
mots
pour exprimer l'essentiel donc on va
essayer de faire ça sans nous que vous
d'ailleurs pour les questions et donc
sans plus tarder entrons dans ces
questions sur les objectifs pour la
présidence française de l'union
européenne que l'on appelle la pf eux
c'est un grand mot c'est horrible mais
ça veut dire sa présidence française de
l'union européenne
vous savez que de par les statuts tous
les six mois un pays prend on va dire la
présidence de l'union européenne le
raccourci consacré et donc c'est au tour
de la france à partir du 1er janvier
2022 ça fait plus de 20 ans que nous
n'avions pas été à la présidence de
l'union européenne et donc c'est un
moment important parce que c'est
présidence on peut en faire ce qu'on
veut être actif ou pas actif et puis à
partir du 1er juillet ce seront nos amis
tchèques qui prendront la succession de
la france donc pour parler avec nous
deux de cette thématique de cette
présidence française de l'union
européenne tout d'abord notre ami jean
louis bourlanges président de la
commission des affaires étrangères à
l'assemblée nationale ancien député
européen
alors mon cher jean lui est ce qu'il
faut en fait attendre beaucoup ou pas
grand-chose cette présidence française
de l'union européenne
et face aux grands enjeux de monde qu'on
voit actuellement est ce que l'idée
c'est d'être dans le pessimisme ou au
contraire dans le positif puis est ce
que finalement ces épreuves qu'on
traverse le qu'ovide crise des sous
marins est ce que finalement dans ces
terribles moments c'est pas aussi une
opportunité un électrochoc salutaire qui
peut nous permettre de repartir vite et
mieux
oui d'abord un mot
tu as dit et c'est que j'étais là que je
m'exprime et en qualité de président
de la commission des affaires étrangères
on sait très bien qui aurait dû parler
ici aujourd'hui en qualité de présidente
de la commission
nous allons tous nous avons une immense
émotion c'est à dire qu'au sein de la
commission elle est générale
transcourants tous les partis politiques
ont une immense ont ils ont une immense
émotion en
découvrant la disparition de marielle et
c'est un regret c'est une une souffrance
même qui anime je crois l'ensemble des
membres de notre commission alors comme
le dit françois la vie la vie politique
l'histoire continue le legs que nous
devons assumer ces dates pour être
fidèle à sa mémoire c'est de réussir ce
qu'elle avait l'ambition de faire ce à
quoi elle a contribué par des rapports
éclatant et par une présidence
extraordinaire au sein de cette
commission je vous assure que nous avons
en tant que modem à travers elle nous
avons vraiment honoré le mandat qui nous
a été donnée par la majorité par
l'ensemble de des membres de l'assemblée
et l assumer cette présidence de la
commission des affaires étrangères avec
le profond avec le respect profond des
valeurs qui sont les nôtres qui sont des
valeurs de rassemblement de dynamisme de
dépassement des conflits
d'affirmation d'une volonté commune nous
opposons la volonté commune à l'hystérie
identité c'est ça qu'elle portait en
elle et c'est ça dont on au sein de la
commission mais je sais bien que c'est
le cas aussi des membres du parlement
européen marielle a été très présente
très active au parlement européen c'est
ça que nous avons en commun excuse moi
tu m'as d'une jeune allemande et des
crêpes
je voulais je voulais dire cela alors
sur sur la combien combien de temps dû
jouer je vais me dira ce que tu manges
et 3,4 je crois que c'est je vais
simplement je laisserais ses fans qui va
parler de la présidence
qu'il fait sa vie quotidienne si je puis
dire
mais je voudrais simplement souligner un
paradoxe
c'est le paradoxe il faut bien voir ça
c'est que la présidence d'un état
présidence de l'union européenne par un
état c'est une mission impossible
parce que le président l'état président
et comme aurait dit en d'autres temps
dre tardieu il a les bras chargés les
enfants des autres
il arrive dans un monde déjà fait avec
des bébés qui ont été conçus avant
qu'ils accèdent à lui-même à la chambre
conjugale et qui sont à moitié formé
quelques uns sont à moitié n'est sont
encore à développer et les idées qui
peuvent être les siennes des enfants qui
seraient les cela il n'aura pas le temps
de les voir grandir six mois c'était ce
qu'avait dit façon dans un numéro
absolument dérisoires bien le scanner un
jour oui il avait dit comme ça parce que
tout le monde hurlait à présent un
discours qui est resté homérique comme
un discours de provocation général à
l'égard des partis pro européens
le sco lui avait dit joie vous n'êtes
pas contents mais ne vous inquiétez pas
si moi c'est vite passé il parlait de sa
propre présidence c'est une des raisons
donc il ya ça il ya le fait qu' on a
écouté l'autre jour en commission des
affaires européennes
clément clément boon qui nous a expliqué
on voit bien la france va suivre tous
les dossiers qui sont en sur la sur la
table alors que le
paradoxe un peu comme ce qui s'est passé
pendant la présidence française de 89 on
a évoqué la chute du mur en est
d'arriver présidence française en juin
89 on est arrivé avec notre petit
programme et en six mois on a libéré
l'europe d'ailleurs à ce qu'ils nous
disaient le parlement européen ne sert à
rien j'ai répondu comment j'ai été élu
en juin 89 six mois plus tard l'europe
entière et libéré alors dites moi que ce
n'est pas assumer mon mandat bon mais on
a donc ce et là on est vraiment une
situation
extraordinaire que je qualifierais très
très brièvement en disant nous sommes
porteurs nous français on dit les
français c'est 20 ans c'est l'allemagne
qui dirige etc c'est vrai c'est faux
d'abord personne ne dirige vous ne
pouvez rien faire en europe si vous
n'êtes pas d'accord l'un avec l'autre
même du temps du général de gaulle quand
les allemands pas voulu suivre de gaulle
ils n'ont pas suivi point final et ça a
été une crise longue au sein de l'europe
donc personne ne domine l'autre c'est
vrai que les allemands ont une puissance
économique une puissance d'entraînement
plus forte que la nôtre actuellement
mais sur le plan décidé je voudrais
qu'on arrête de dire que l'europe est
dirigée par les allemands ce qui est
caractéristique c'est que les idées que
nous avons avec d'autres avec les
italiens avec les espagnols
avec avec les benelux 1 et avec d'autres
ce que nous avons mis en place au
lendemain de maastricht ce sont des
idées qui enfin se concrétise nous avons
dit quoi nous avons dit l'europe c'est
pas simplement que les pays européens se
regarde les uns les autres c'est qu'ils
regardent ensemble pour paraphraser
saint-exupéry dans la même direction il
faut faire une révolution copernicienne
le destin de l'europe il se jouera dans
ses rapports avec la chine avec l'inde
avec moyen-orient avec l'afrique avec
l'amérique parce que le problème franco
allemand il est heureusement réglé donc
il faut faire une grande conversion ça
veut dire qu'on doit faire une europe
politique ça veut dire qu'on doit faire
non pas simplement une politique
monétaire mais une politique économique
ça veut dire qu'on doit s'intéresser aux
mouvements migratoires n'ont pas non pas
pour refuser systématiquement les
migrants mais pour réguler
l'émigration et pour réussir
l'intégration ça veut dire qu'on doit
relever les défis proprement politique
est d'abord le défi écologique qui est
le nôtre qu'est ce qui se passe depuis
quelques temps on voit que nos idées ont
germé les allemands madame madame merkel
avec la prudence qui l'a toujours
caractérisé a fait un grand choix avec
next generation l'année dernière et
maintenant on voit bien que le grand
enjeu c'est de savoir comment on va
transformer notre ce qui s'est fait ce
plan de relance qui doit pas être un one
shot mouvement plan mais un plan comment
on va le transformer ce qui s'est passé
en afghanistan
ça a révélé une immense un immense vide
moi je crois qu'il y avait deux façons
de traiter la deux façons de traiter le
le pivot
le pivot américain soit les américains
c'était un peu la tendance de trump 10
on se fout des européens et on s'oriente
vers la chine soit et c'est ptet est ce
encore c'est ça le problème la tendance
de baden en janvier en disant comme nous
allons être concentrés par le pacifique
il faut que les européens s'unissent
s'autonomise et prennent leurs
responsabilités pour gérer ce que
j'appelle une véritable verticale du
vide qui va à vue du cap du du pôle nord
jusque au sud de l'afrique en passant
par l'europe je fus les pales que cette
semaine sont très inquiet en passant par
la méditerranée qui n'est plus du tout
protégé organisé en passant par le sahel
en passant par le moyen-orient est là le
problème qui s'est posé dans le couac
l'immense quoique des sous-marins cecb
hayden a assemblé dire bah non ce que
j'ai dit ça ne compte pas en fait
l'europe je m'en fous je me fie joe
radle de rompre ap les relations via non
maintenant il s'agit de savoir si nous
sommes capables de nous organiser nous
avons l'enjeu migratoires nous avons
l'enjeu technologique il est absolument
anormal qu'un pays comme taiwan qui a 30
millions d'habitants soit le roi des
semis conduite heures et que nous
habitons 450 millions d'habitants nous
peignons à exister dans ce domaine donc
voilà les grands défis voilà les grands
défis et
cdti nous les portons nous français le
président macron depuis son discours de
la sorbonne nous les portons nous allons
certainement franchir des étapes assez
importante dans tous ces domaines à
travers la la présidence française mais
l'essentiel c'est que nous puissions
nous en france poursuivre la tâche je
vous dis pas comment il faut voter aux
présidentielles vous avez votre petite
idée pour poursuivre cette tâche et il
faut aussi qu'on rencontre en allemagne
des notamment mais c'est le reste il
faudra les italiens ça va bien ça va
beaucoup mieux on est très heureux que
les italiens les espagnols c'est très
intéressant nous avons des problèmes
avec les polonais les hongrois et cetera
mais on les arrête mais le problème
c'est d'abord l'allemagne il faut que
l'allemagne comme nous
accepte le la grande métamorphose du
projet européen qui doit cesser d'être
technocratique simplement économique qui
doit devenir pleinement politique nous
défendons nous avons défendu la paix
entre nous nous devons construire la
paix dans le monde nous avons une
civilisation dont nous devons être fiers
que nous n'avons pas à rechercher ou
comme on dit maintenant à quand ce lait
et pour réussir cette opération comme on
l'a dit dans ce dans ce document on le
fera tous ensemble voilà c'est un
maillon dans la chaîne cette présidence
française mais l'essentiel ce sera les
années à venir est ce que nous saurons
faire avec un président macron réélu et
avec une allemagne qui acceptera de
faire avec sa prudence son réalisme mais
aussi son ambition ce virage nécessaire
du projet européen merci jean louis
alors les allemands on va s'est
rapidement savoir ce qu'il en est
puisque dans 48 heures ils ont leur vote
et on aura bientôt les nouvelles sorties
des urnes allemande et puis le président
macron mais on va en parler maintenant
avec stéphane ces journées qui nous fait
l'amitié d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation lors stéphane ces journées il
est député européen il est président de
la délégation française renaissance au
parlement européen qui regroupe des
députés de 1,8 en marche du modem du
mouvement radical et d'agir et il est
par ailleurs conseiller du président de
la république alors stéphane on voudrait
un petit peu savoir au niveau des
produits étaient françaises ou est ce qu
on en est tous les choix ne sont pas
arrêtés évidemment mais il ya déjà un
groupe de travail qui a été fait tant au
niveau du parlement européen par notre
équipe que par les ministères que par
les différents partis politiques et
jean-noël barrot a rappelé tout à
l'heure le travail que le modem a fait
en interne sur cette question là où
est-ce qu'on en ait et voilà peut-être
un calendrier puis des éléments concrets
de ces primes étaient françaises merci
stéphane bon merci merci beaucoup pour
l'invitation et merci de me faire passer
après jean louis bourlanges c'est
toujours très facile
on a toujours
c'est là on voit que l'expérience est
importante en politique mais mais je
voulais d'abord vous remercier et
christophe va me tuer sur le timing je
vais vraiment essayer de faire court
mais je voudrais en préalable puisque
vous vous le savez aussi on a une
délégation au parlement européen de 23
députés 23 députés je pense que qui sont
dans une situation y compris politiques
au centre de l'hémicycle européen où on
gagne un peu près 95 % de nos votes au
parlement européen et on est dans une
situation on peut pas faire sans nous
dans cet hémicycle européens ce qui est
une situation un peu inédite dans
laquelle cette délégation française au
sein de ce groupe là et avec 23
individus mais je voudrais d'abord
remercier et vous dire quel point vos
parlementaires du modem travail je pense
qu'on est en train de faire changer y
compris la vision qu'avaient les
européens de la france dans cette
institution a beaucoup critiqué les
français comme étant un mandat de voie
de garage pour les parlementaires
nationaux qui avaient perdu leur mandat
local ou national
on avait des vrais problèmes d'assiduité
sur certaines sur certaines délégations
je ne parle pas de cette famille
politique là mais avant il y avait eu
vraiment des problèmes d'assiduité et je
pense que le travail qu'on est en train
de mener depuis deux ans et je voudrais
d'abord vous remercier et remercier les
parlementaires modem qui travaillent
dans cette délégation parce que vous
faites vraiment du bon travail et je
pense que vous pouvez les applaudir
petite parenthèse mais si je le dis pas
personne ne dit donc
bon merci d'abord aussi puisqu'on va
rentrer dans un moment important un
moment important parce que je pense que
l'europe a pris conscience que dans le
triptyque
les états unis 9 la chine produit
l'europe réguler il fallait innover et
aussi produire et gagner notre
souveraineté européenne
si je résume un petit peu ce que ce que
ce que disait jean louis bourlanges
cette présidence française avait être
sous cette optique là il va falloir
continuer à réguler puisque notre
réglementation européenne est pas encore
abouti il va falloir consolider le
modèle européen qu'on est en train de
construire c'est ce qu'on va faire sur
l'environnement avec des objectifs de
décarbonation de l'économie à 2050 qui
va falloir quand même expliquer à tous
nos concitoyens européens comme on y
arrive et avec une réglementation bien
établi une quinzaine de propositions de
règlements et directives qui sortent de
la commission qu'on va devoir analyser
rapidement et peut-être faire aboutir en
présidence française notamment des gros
objets politiques comme la taxe carbone
aux frontières de l'union européenne qui
nécessitera justement beaucoup de
pédagogie de notre part pour expliquer
aux français ce que c est et beaucoup de
pédagogie aussi auprès nos colonnes nos
collègues européens pour les inciter à
adopter ce modèle on aura ils sont
drôles en dira sûrement un mot mais
aussi à parachever la régulation sur le
numérique qui a un vrai sujet donc mon
créer une identité numérique européenne
qui sera pas ni le modèle chinois ni le
modèle d'ailleurs américain et qui sera
un vrai modèle particulier de
compétition mais aussi
de régulation du secteur du numérique ça
on vous en parlera aussi et puis dans le
troisième aspect peut-être
on aura également tous les combats qu'on
voit qu'on va venir sur l'état de droit
avec une délégation ultra mobilisés et
sur les questions sociales je sais que
voilà sylvie est là notre député qui va
s'en occuper avec la construction
peut-être d'un salaire minimum européen
dans les pays qui ne l'ont pas encore
aujourd'hui je le dis bien je le précise
pour pas que ça soit interprété comme
dans ça a été dans pareil dans la
campagne européenne mal interprétés j'ai
pas de niveler par le bas les salaires
minimum européen mais de construire ce
modèle social européen donc si je résume
mois les choses je dirai à la fois
parachever le modèle de régulation
prendre conscience que l'autonomie
stratégique et dans l'innovation et dans
la fable et dans l'est dans la
fabrication ne doit pas être
exclusivement renvoyer aux deux autres
continents et donc je pense que ça on
aura un intérêt est dans le moment qu'on
a vécu avec l'afghanistan et les sous
marins nucléaires
et le ce contrat d'armement je pense
qu'on est dans un moment de bascule
aussi on arrivera à faire
accélérer tous ces jeunes gens d'al la
présidente de la commission d'ailleurs
22 ryan a annoncé un grand sommet sur la
défense européenne c'est vraiment une
première et on va pouvoir accélérer
l'agenda sur ces questions là donc
beaucoup chantier il faudrait presque
deux heures pour
prendre chantier par chantier mais par
contre je sais que c'est le travail des
mouvements politiques de creuser
d'expliquer de vulgariser et surtout de
convaincre les français que la défense
du modèle européen va être aussi un
enjeu politique dans les prochaines
les prochaines années dans l'est dans
les années à venir et je pense qu'on
peut compter sur le modem en tout cas
vous pourrez compter sur la république
en marche et l'ensemble de la délégation
renaissance jour merci merci stéphane
alors vous l'aurez compris en écoutant
jean louis et stéphane ceux qui
imaginent l'europe comme uniquement un
grand marché commun dérégulé monétaire
vous voyez bien qu'aujourd'hui c'est des
vrais politiques économiques c'est la
fin de l'europe naïve c'est l'autonomie
stratégique
c'est aussi le retour des valeurs et de
cet attachement à l'état de droit qui
avait peut-être été un petit peu perdues
évidemment ça nécessite de se bagarrer
alors pour arriver à tous ces éléments
qui sont en fait quelques briques de
proférer mur
richard ferrand nous parlait tout à
l'heure de fondations et de son père qui
était maçon donc pour faire un mur il
faut aussi avoir dumortier avoir du
liant et le liant chère laurence parent
c'est aussi quelque part le sentiment
d'appartenance
l'identification européenne le le ce
sentiment d'appartenance notamment pour
la jeunesse puisque ursula von der leyen
nous a annoncé l'année 2022 comme étant
de l'année européenne de la jeunesse
alors il va falloir que vous nous
expliquer un petit peu tout cela je
rappelle que vous êtes députée
européenne coordinatrice de la
commission culture au parlement européen
est également membre de la conférence
pour l'avenir de l'europe laurence
oui alors il ya un moment c'est vrai six
mois c'est court pour la présidence
française de l'union européenne
mais c'est la présidence de l'état le
plus pro européen et deuxièmement on
arrive à ce moment où
simultanément ce qui a été voulu par la
france ce qui a été voulu par le
président macron est porté par notre
groupe politique c'est à dire la
conférence pour l'avenir de l'europe
arrive cette conférence qui a pour
objectif
de bouger et de toucher à certains
[Musique]
éléments de fonctionnement pour aller
vers 7h plus politique et à la fois de
se tourner vers les citoyens pour les
écouter et faire en sorte qu'ils
s'approprient cette europe parce qu'en
effet dans cette présidence française de
l'union européenne il ya un triptyque
très intéressant qui a été développée
qui est relance puissance et
appartenance est en effet l'appartenance
c'est ce dont on a besoin pour partir
ensemble à l'assaut des grands combats
parce que assumer les efforts que
représente l'adaptation au changement
climatique avancer vers une régulation
de l'économie et vers une fiscalité plus
ambitieuse de faire une égalité
aller vers l'autonomie stratégique voire
vers une défense tout ça si on se sent
pas ensemble réunis autour d'un grand
récit on peut pas l'obtenir et on peut
pas l'achever donc c'est ce qui
m'intéresse en effet plus
particulièrement dans mon travail
parlementaire au sein de la commission
éducation culture parce que en effet
quel est le récit que nous partageons
c'est vraiment la grande difficulté on
se réfère à la paix pour les états
fondateurs pour lé père fondateur mais
c'est déjà loin pour les générations
nouvelles mais aussi c'est une autre
histoire l'europe les états qui nous ont
rejoints après 1989 pour eux l'histoire
c'est la conquête démocratique
donc on à ce sujet de ce récit commun
qu'on doit partager face aux états unis
les cowboys beyoncé disney et
minutes et puis d'un bloc totalitaire
alès qui a été l'urss et qui est
aujourd'hui la chine mais il ya une
question c'est que tout ce qui fait ce
ciment il est dans des zones moins
influente de l'europe l'éducation la
culture qui sont des compétences
vraiment annexe de l'union européenne et
qui sont pourtant si européenne est si
important de pardon et bien sûr la
question de la citoyenneté est ça la
question de citoyenneté c'est vraiment
un
espace non investis pour lequel on doit
se battre et c'est pour ça que
l'exercice de la conférence est très
intéressant parce que ça dit comment je
me sens citoyen comment je me sens
op 1 et il faut vraiment qu'on ait cette
participation massive de se dire qu'est
ce qui fait que au delà du moment où je
passe la frontière où j'ai mon passeport
ça fasse sens d'être un citoyen européen
ce qui est remarquable c'est que les
jeunes participent beaucoup à ce sujet
sur tous les éléments de consultation
qu'on a sur les plates formes delà de la
conférence pour l'union européenne est à
la fois à travers la première réunion
vous savez la conférence il ya 200
citoyens qui ont été tirés au sort dont
un tiers de 16-25 ans donc c'est bien
c'est une place d'importante donner aux
jeunes ils se sont massivement prononcés
sur ce sujet donc citoyenneté deuxième
sujet sur lequel la présidence sera
vraiment opéré et clément bonne nous l'a
répété et on travaille avec nos
ministres de référence l'éducation et la
culture l'éducation
là aussi sur les premières remarques
remontée conte à la question
d'harmonisation qui aujourd'hui
illusoire il faut pas forcément plus
harmoniser tout l'éducation mais c'est
stratégique parce que d'une part on doit
atteindre parler d'innovation stéphane
une excellence académique pour avoir des
chercheurs pour avoir du talent de la
matière grise est à la fois augmenter
notre potentiel démocratique en donnant
plus d'accès à l'éducation en ça on a la
chance d'avoir un programme emblématique
erasmus plus et ce programme erasmus
plus il est amené à évoluer encore pour
je crois que la table ronde qui suit et
l'égalité des chances mais se sentir
citoyens égaux à égalité des chances
partout en europe c'est un combat clé
donc on a une proposition qui est très
partagée par le ministère par nono nos
adhérents aussi puisqu'elle est dans
notre proposition du livre blanc c'est
la question du statut européen des
apprentis en mobilité puisqu'aujourd'hui
on sait que la mobilité européenne le
fait de pouvoir acquérir des compétences
s'adresse surtout aux étudiants du
supérieur or le programme erasmus plus
inclut maintenant cette dimension donc
je crois pouvoir dire que la france
pourra aller plus 1 et on sait très bien
que quand on touche des jeunes en
apprentissage
de fait on démocratise parce que c'est
des jeunes qui ont souvent quitté le
cursus est qui et c'est une manière de
créer ce ciment est une manière de créer
l'appartenance deuxième sujet pour
dernier sujet pour être rapide et
passait la parole c'est la question de
la culture qui est tout à fait clé la
culture qui est vraiment le parent
pauvre de de l'union européenne puisque
on est à 0,2 pour cent du budget et qui
est si importante mais là aussi signe
d'espoir
notre groupe a porté notre délégation a
porté une résolution parlement européen
dans le cadre de la relance pour que des
budget soit fléchir on a obtenu 2 %
enfin c'est une recommandation qu'on a
fait pour que 2% des plans de relance
soient fléché par la culture est
aujourd'hui à l'échelle de l'union
européenne des 27 on a ce chiffre alors
avec des disparités la france n'est bien
sûr bonne élève il y en ad'autres
république tchèque à 4%
d'autres en 0 mais c'est l'allemagne
parce qu'ils ont délégué les compétences
aux régions hollander mais
tracy très positifs et dans ceux
questions culturelles il ya vraiment des
points qu'on doit s'arroger et là aussi
je suis confiante parce qu on y
travaille on échange beaucoup avec les
ministères sur des questions comme la
langue multilinguisme importance
d'acquérir notre identité avec cette
complexité qu'est la diversité et au
delà puisque c'est un sujet qui nous a
touché les langues régionales la
reconnaissance des cultures régionales
parce que l'europe ça doit pas être une
uniformité absolument triste
donc on à cette question notamment de la
charte la ratification des chartes
régionales et minoritaires qui est
importante et qui rejoint le débat qu'on
a eue sur la loi molac et dans nos
régions aussi voilà point le patrimoine
caisse là aussi parce que on sait la
difficulté qui a enseigné l'histoire
européenne compte tenu de justement nos
différentes visions sur l'histoire en
revanche très accaparé le patrimoine
l'exploit l'explorer et l'exploiter le
communiqué c'est aussi leur prendre aux
plus conservateurs ceux qui revendiquent
le patrimoine au parlement européen
c'est pas les parties les plus pro
europe 1 et puis on a beaucoup de sujets
tu parlais du numérique et s'en trouve
en reparler certainement c'est l'europe
à l'heure du numérique et du digital il
ya des directives très importantes qui
sont passés dans l'ancienne mandature
pour que ce qui fait le contact
aujourd'hui avec les citoyens
c'est-à-dire pour beaucoup les
programmes de vod en ligne et biens
intègres 30% de production européenne
pour que le pour que le la production
audiovisuelle soit financé aussi donc
tous s'achemine c'est un progrès qui est
fait c'est 2% et je pense que c'est pas
un hasard si il ya eu le premier g20
culture merci sandro à rome en italie
qui s'est penché sur le sujet donc pour
conclure
c'est un moment nous avons besoin de
dépassement et d'objectifs politiques
mais rien ne se fera sans ciment et sans
ce sentiment d'appartenance merci
laurence
alors vous avez cité clément bonne notre
secrétaire d'état aux affaires
européennes peut-être vous rappeler que
cet après midi à 14h30 dans cette salle
et en diffusera le son message en vidéo
notre ministre des affaires européennes
alors sandro gozi
ancien ministre des affaires européennes
du gouvernement italien
député européen membre de la queue de la
conférence pour l'avenir de l'europe
secrétaire général du parti démocrate
européen le ppe je vous rappelle quand
même que le pdc est une émanation de
l'âme du mouvement démocrate à l'origine
et de nos amis italiens donc c'est comme
ça que le pds est constituée il ya
quelques années et qu'il fédère
aujourd'hui des partis politiques dans
une bonne partie de l'europe peut-être
important de le rappeler parce qu'il ya
toujours marqué p2 quelque part sur les
sur les documents mais peut-être vous
rappeler un peu ce que c'est parce que
c'est vrai que en france on ne connaît
peut-être pas suffisamment encore tout
est membre du modem vous êtes membre de
droit du pdo donc voilà donc c'est donc
voilà vous êtes adhérentes quelque chose
que vous ne connaissez pas forcément
encore à 100% alors que françois bayrou
se bat depuis l'origine entend aussi que
président pour pour que le p2 soit
encore plus connu et donc merci à sandro
également cette qualité de secrétaire
général du parti démocrate alors qu'elle
peut-être quels objectifs sur la
conférence sur l'avenir de l'europe en
complément de ce qu'a déjà dit laurence
et puis voilà comment impliquer
davantage les citoyens dans cet euro peu
de demain sans van persie merci un
nouveau merci c'est la quatrième fois
que je suis allé à citer des rentrées du
modem la deuxième fois guidel une fois
au sud-ouest une fois de suite un sens
très bien jean louis l'a déjà dit mais
vu la relation qu'on avait je dois vous
le dire aussi combien j'ai fermement que
la présence de marielle c'est avec elle
que j'ai commencé
notre belle amitié notre belle
coopération entre nous un italien et
vous les moments démocrate et on venons
ici le soir j'ai pas pu m'empêcher des
débuts vers 1h une pensée très amicale
et très douce parce qu'elle me manque
énormément
[Applaudissements]
mission impossible
on a des missions impossibles a toujours
des missions impossibles en politique
c'est pour cela qu'on fait de la
politique d'ailleurs et c'est pour cela
qu'on fait de la politique européenne
c'est mission impossible
la présidence française de l'union
européenne jean louis et stéphane
encadré et parfaitement les enjeux c'est
mission impossible aussi de transformer
l'europe et de faire une conférence
l'avenir de l'europe en sélectionnons
des citoyens qui vont sont plusieurs
centaines et citoyen été sélectionnés
dans les 27 états membres pour
travailler dans cette conférence avec
les représentants des citoyens avec nous
les parlementaires européens avec les
rappeler parlementaires nationaux avec
des ministres avec les commissaires ça
c'est la conférence est ce que c'est il
ya certains qui ne voulaient pas cette
conférence il y en a d'autres qui
voudraient qu'elle ça se passe vite et
qu'on oublie vite il y en a d'autres
encore qui disent à ce formidable c'est
un grand sondage à l'échelle
continentale
et puis à nous
nous nous voulons qu'ils aient la
conférence prépare une grande réforme de
l'union européenne certains grains de
réformer l'union européenne et nous
voulons que ceci coïncide avec un grand
moment pendant la présidence française
de l'union européenne nous voulons c'est
là parce que c'est nécessaire nous
voulons cela parce que moi je dis tout
le temps
surtout avec la crise ducobu disney mais
en général avec ce changement ces
nouveaux désordres
mondiale on vit un moment d'arméniens
moment des grands changements un moment
dans les caisses n'est pas toujours le
plus fort qui gagne mais c'est lui qui
montre d'avoir la meilleure capacité
d'adaptation les lieux des mieux
interpréter la transformation et dans
ces moments d'avignon mondiale nous les
européens nous devons à interpréter les
besoins des transformations on a déjà
commencé lors on se le dise et à
travailler avec les citoyens les
citoyens nous disent c'est que
stéphane et laurent sont rappelés ils
veulent du multilinguisme ils veulent
une nouvelle régulation plus juste du
numérique
ils veulent
une europe des valeurs
gens lui disaient
c'est un peu ingrat avoir une présidence
en rotation pour 6 mois 1 2 million
européenne moi je peux te le dire c'est
que moi j'étais les coordinateurs de la
présidence malienne 2014 à l'époque
j'avais me compromettez la protection de
l'état de droit tu as vu combien de
temps j'ai dû attendre
pour voir pour voir quelques avancées
sur lesquels nous sommes très engagés
est ce que les criquets nous avons nous
allons continuer donc les les enjeux
sont ceux là mais il faut d'un côté les
placer dans un contexte plus vaste de
l'autre côté voir dans l'immédiat c'est
que on peut obtenir dans ces six mois et
les contextes plus plus bas c'est ce
qu'e on va célébrer les 30 ans du marché
unique grand succès européen c'est en
l'année prochaine les 35 ans du du
programme du projet les plus connus et
les plus de succès en europe c'est les
programmes erasmus et nous avons un
grand nos rites et c'est comment être
plus autonomes
pour assurer notre notre notre stabilité
pour assure pour assurer nos intérêts
c'est le thème de l'autonomie
stratégique
c'est ça les contextes donc les marché
unique a été un grand succès aujourd'hui
nous devons construire les robes du
numérique des marché unique numérique du
point de vue des opportunités que cela
c'est là aux offres du point de vue de
la protection
des droits fondamentaux du point de vue
des nouvelles opportunités que cela peut
donner à un autre modèle industriel de
la volonté stéphane a dit très bien d
être
véritablement alternatif un modèle où
tout est réglementé ou l'écran légion du
numérique font ce qu'ils veulent avec
nos données personnelles les modèles
américains et un modèle où tout est
étatique et dans lesquelles est
numérique est utilisé pour contrôler les
citoyens et pour interférer dans nos
processus démocratique c'est les modèles
chinois et le travail qu'on fait aussi
de la dent la commission d' enquête sur
la désinformation montre bien combien
les russes les chinois les îles et les
iraniens le venezuela utilise les
instruments numériques pour interférer
sur nos processus démocratique se sent
face dans les enjeux ok ok nous devons
faire face en sachant qu'il ya aussi et
ce sera des derniers points en sachant
qu'il y a aussi d'abord la nécessité
d'une approche humaniste
la question de la sécurité pour moi
n'est pas seulement militaire
la question de la sécurité européenne
ces militaires et culture
autonomie stratégique et connaissances
l'éducation et moi je lui dis que un
message très fort ça serait que pour un
euro de plus qu en tant qu'européens en
dépenses pour l'armée on doit dépenser
un euro plus pour la culture passe et
c'est comme ça que nous défendons
véritablement dé façon complète nos
valeurs et nous avons la possibilité de
faire passer d'un côté justement des
prix une des priorités de la présidence
française d'une europe 1 ce sera la
défense de l'autre côté ça sera tout les
initiatives là demain d'éducation de
culture du numérique qui nous allons que
nous allons lancer et après il ya un
contexte
drider chipe la comtesse de leadership
un contexte des relations complexes des
travail avec les acteurs incontournables
par des passants exclusive mais
incontournable dans les limites et les
leaders aujourd'hui en europe s'appelle
emmanuel macron donc il faut bien les ré
lire en 2022
il a un bon partenaire
il a un bon partenaire qui s'appelle
mario draghi est ce cher jean louis je
suis content que tu dises que ça va très
bien avec l'italie mais si des papes
pour quelqu'un que vous connaissez bien
qu'ils s'appellent matures et une fille
qui a provoqué la crise pour remplacer
du cp comptait pas mario draghi
aujourd'hui les relations entre l'italie
et feront ne seraient pas les mêmes donc
moi je vous rappeler cette opération qui
a été fondamental pas seulement pour
l'italie mais aussi mais aussi pour
l'europe et puis il ya la grande
question allemande et je termine là je
sais combien elle est
historique forte combien la question de
la relation entre la france et
l'allemagne sont ciblés ce terrain moi
dans mon expérience
j'ai trouvé que est la prudence - à la
prudence parfois désespérante des angles
américaine j'ai toujours préféré dépit
qu'il est candidat l'impatience qui peut
être énervé certains des menus et macro
et moi j'espère que la chancellière les
nouveaux champs cédiez la nouvelle
chancelière soit elle ou lui aussi un
peu plus impatients d transformer notre
union européenne merci lisandro
alors
juste jusqu'à maintenant on a eu un
regard un petit peu de l'europe
occidentale j'allais dire avec avec nos
différents intervenants est peut-être
temps de se tourner vers la partie de
l'europe orientale cette offre des pays
de l'est que frédéric petit connaît
parfaitement donc se référer que vous
êtes député à l'assemblée nationale
représentant les français de l'étranger
notamment dans cette partie de l'europe
et vous êtes également secrétaire
général adjoint du parti démocrate
européen alors frédéric comment est-ce
qu'on peut dans cet idéal européen
peut-être dans cette histoire que
laurence est évoquée également où c'est
pas facile parce qu'il n'a pas forcément
les mêmes histoires pas forcément les
mêmes cultures comment est-ce qu'on peut
davantage impliquiez ce qu'on appelait
autrefois les pays de l'est dans dans
cet idéal européen
oui merci je vais je ne suis donc pas
député européen des gens dont les pays
où j'habite et où je vis qui ont du mal
à comprendre qui je suis exactement
parce que ça n'existe pas dans les
autres pays ce que je représente donc je
vais faire des peut-être des remarques
de terrain
mais par rapport à ce que je suis et
j'aime bien dans mes réunions publiques
parce que j'ai des réunions publiques à
tirana à belgrade etc j'aime bien
renverser le slogan du front national
c'est assez satisfaisant pour l'esprit
en disant on est chez nous
le fameux slogan gay on est chez nous
qui exclut en moi je dis on est chez
nous et on ait donc un lien et c'est
assez intéressant alors de remarques et
puis je serais assez court
il ya une autre image que je prends
assez souvent quand je suis en
particulier dans les balkans c'est de
dire que les balkans sont l'avenir de
l'europe je parle des balkans 6
évidemment tout le monde dise le député
il est fatigué c'est le contraire c'est
l'europe qui l'avenir des balkans ça
sera à l'ordre du jour et quand je dis
ça je le pense sincèrement parce que
comme je le dis dans la vidéo l'europe
c'est pas
l'accord multilatéral qu'on a fait dans
la paix c'est vrai on oublie souvent que
la sarre étaient françaises
le bade wurtemberg
n'était pas l'allemagne c'était une zone
d'occupation moi je rencontre j'ai fêté
ya pas longtemps les 50 ans du lycée
français de baden baden on m'a raconté
des histoires
d'envahissement de français dans
l'allemagne il y avait là il y avait les
conflits dans la rue et c'est assez mou
jusqu'en 65 66 et c'est à ces moments là
qu'on a créé qu on s'est dit on va alors
qu'on a encore des conflits ouverts on
va mettre en commun le charbon l'acier
puis la langue de l'autre un peu plus
tard et c'est en ça que cette partie de
l'europe peut être l'avenir de l'europe
ou bien notre modèle de réconciliation
entre ennemis héréditaires et de
transformation des conflits pour aller
pour apporter au monde une autre parole
marche et dans ces cas là c'est là bas
que ça va marcher maintenant ou alors
c'est qu'on s'est trompé donc je crois
qu'il ya une notion et qui est une
notion est effectivement une notion
culturelle une notion de culture
européenne est la dernière chose que je
voudrais dire c'est une précision je
crois pas qu'on sera ce que fera
l'allemagne dimanche soir dimanche soir
ils ont analysé après ils vont faire ils
vont faire une coalition mais le pire ce
sera pas à faire le plus long ça sera
pas la coalition elle même la coalition
on peut les ja la sentir ça sera
l'accord de coalition parce que dans
l'accord de coalition et sont obligés de
faire des tractations voilà si le fdp
dans la coalition qu'est ce que le fdp
va accepter de céder ou pas céder ça
sera pas pareil pour le train sera pas
pareil pour la culture donc je crois
qu'on a encore une menace une menace sur
la présidence française
c'est quand même de revivre ce qu'on a
vécu il ya cinq ans c'est à dire une
très très longue un très très long
d'accord de coalition ce qui ferait que
sa maîtresse à nous handicaperait au
niveau européen
merci frédéric un sens ce qui avait été
extrêmement surprenant c'est
effectivement d'avoir en allemagne qu'il
y ait fallu attendre trois débats
télévisés que pour ce troisième débat
télévisé on commence à parler d'europe
entre candidats à la chancellerie band
qui est absolument incroyable bon ils
sont tous d'accord ils sont tous pro
européen maintenant avaya que les
extrêmes à gauche et à l'extrême droite
qui ne sont pas favorables l'europe donc
une sorte de consensus mais c'est bien
de le rappeler quand même d'un débat
public
mais aussi trois bva pour commencer à
dire du mal les uns des autres il faut
dire que dieu nous commencerons beaucoup
plus tôt on a toujours un temps d'avancé
bien ok allons maintenant merci à nos
intervenants c'est le moment des
questions je vous avais dit qu'on
voulait pas faire un entre nous mais que
c'était un avec vous qu'on voulait faire
donc si des mains peuvent se lever je
vois plein de mains qui se lèvent or
s'il vous plaît des questions
extrêmement concise
j'anticipe les demandes de la régie donc
question très concise s'il vous plaît
pourquoi et puis on va faire des
réponses de toute façon concise donc ça
permettra d'avoir un maximum et j'en
prends plusieurs d'un coup très bien des
hordes avec plaisir alors il ya trop de
mains qui se lèvent d'ailleurs jeu quand
le micro distribuer les vous peut-être
ça faisait plus facile
oui
mon mari vous n'avez pas parlé un
instant du bric site
c'est
presque c'est parce qu'on va enchaîner
plusieurs questions on va enchaîner
plusieurs plusieurs questions
oui oui une question en fait par rapport
à quels objectifs pour la présidence
française de l'union européenne
moi je suis enseignant et jean louis
bourlanges a vraiment parlé à ses
politiques dimanche dernier 2 du giec et
des rapports sur le climat est vraiment
je veux dire ici que la tempe des
lycéens sur la question du climat est
énorme elle est vraiment énorme et si
emmanuel macron avait un objectif à se
fixer ce serait peut-être de proposer à
l'europe une europe de l'énergie par
exemple et je voulais vous demander
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est quelle
chance ce projet at-il d'aboutir en
europe merci beaucoup
et une troisième question et on va
commencer à répondre dernière question
comment gérer
une présidence française jean dionis
lot-et-garonne une présidence française
en même temps qu'une campagne
présidentielle quels sont les recours
circuit qui peut y avoir et comment vous
allez donc nous abriter de ses courts
circuits deuxième question pendant les
six mois n'oubliez pas la logistique
fonctionnement de l'europe tout ce que
vous pourrez faire pour améliorer
l'administration
territoriale des fonds européens il faut
le faire il ya un énorme travail à faire
sa flotte entre une gestion nationale et
une gestion au niveau des régions et je
salue ma collègue donc laurence bonjour
laurence et donc la veillée pas peur
d'avoir des objectifs modestes aussi
d'amélioration de l'efficacité de la
machine européenne
merci alors 100 euros un mot sur le bris
site
déjà vous avez dans votre dans votre
question il y avait la réponse mais je
vous je vous dis en anecdotes en dix
minutes où cela veut dire là est venu
devant nous les parlementaires européens
pour faire un discours sur l'état de
l'union les grands discours les grands
moments politiques 1 entre notamment la
commission le parlement européen mais
pour l'europe dans lesquels on indique
quels sont les grands enjeux les
priorités les préoccupations pour
l'année devant nous et n'a jamais
prononcé les mots briques site
est passé qui pour nous c'est derrière
nous c'est derrière nous et les
correspondants britannique à
strasbourg qui suivait ils ont discuté
avec leurs collègues français
allemand mais en dix ans elle n'a jamais
parlé du bric site eh oui donc c'est ça
pour nous on a on a un continent à bâtir
on a une robe transformé on a des
réponses à donner à nos citoyens l'été
reste des reines ou évidemment nous
voulons construire un partenariat avec
nos amis britanniques
mais contrairement à ce qu'ils avaient
pensé on passe pas nos journées à nous
demander c'est qu'est ce qu'ils vont
faire les britanniques au nous a arraché
les cheveux pour leur choix dramatique
est une erreur historique démocratique
et nous respectons mais nous allons de
l'avant et c'est bon c'est là que nous
pouvons ses derniers mots construire
aller de l'avant vers une europe de la
défense
merci merci sandro précisé aussi qu'il
faudra veiller la seule actualité qui
nous reste un peu que les britanniques
parce qu'il respecte la signature ce
qu'ils ont signés que les engagements
soient bien tenu et que les choses
fonctionnent bel et bien si vous me
permettez par rapport à la question sur
l'énergie je vais répondre à la baisse
de nos invités mais donc c'est majeur
les questions d'énergie je m'en occupe
un peu au parlement européen
l'intégration des systèmes énergétiques
maintenant là je m'occupe de la révision
de la directive sur les énergies
renouvelables dont qui est un enjeu
absolument majeur cet enjeu énergétique
pas pour de la décroissance je dis à
chaque fois que ce qui est important
c'est de effectivement de faire de
l'efficacité énergétique de faire des
économies de mieux isoler le bâtiment et
c est pour mieux redémarrer
l'énergie parce que l'énergie consommée
est toujours lié au niveau de vie des
pays au pib donc plus vous dépensez
d'énergie plus vous avez de pib à partir
du moment où vous respecter la nature et
que vous n'utilisez pas les ressources
finies eh bien on a tous les leviers
ouvert pour redéployer derrière et donc
c'est évidemment le green deal au niveau
du parlement européen fin au niveau des
textes du parlement européen au niveau
de l'union c'est le green deal donc la
neutralité carbone en 2050 sur laquelle
on se bagarre tous avec là aussi dépassé
un peu les dogmes françois parler de ça
ce matin
le problème de l'énergie c'est qu'ils
aient beaucoup d'hommes je prends
l'exemple en 2050 il faut 13 % d'énergie
nucléaire en 2050 dans le mix
énergétique s'il n'ya pas 13% on
n'arrive pas des carboné en 2050
il ya quand même des gens qui
aujourd'hui veulent mettre des bâtons
dans les roues parce qu'ils veulent pas
de ces 13 % en 2050 donc ça veut dire
qu'ils veulent pas l'objectif de vienne
ville et donc on se bagarre avec la
taxonomie verte avec d'autres sujets
pour qu'il y ait une part de nucléaire
dedans ça veut pas dire que c'est la
seule solution mais il ya une part à
mettre dedans sinon on n'y arrivera pas
et donc sur la troisième question
relatif l'élection présidentielle en
même temps que la présidence je pense
que stéphane ces journées est le mieux
placé pour pour nous en parler alors
est-ce qui aura six mois utiles ou trois
mois utiles ou comment on va faire avec
une question qui revient souvent sur
deux sujets est ce que la présidentielle
est un élément handicapant pour notre
efficacité en la présidence de l'union
européenne est ce que c'est un élément
on va dire supplémentaires qui
pourraient nous faire gagner un peu plus
d'efficacité dans la dynamique qu'on a
moi j'ai envie de dire ni l'un ni
l'autre et je mets à témoin mais mes
collègues ici rond je pense qu'on aurait
préparé de la même manière la présidence
française
qui est présidentielle ou pas
présidentielle l'enjeu et le moment
politique qu'on a vécu avec le poste
avait admis ce temps avec le moment on
sent bien
brick site étant passé je rejoins les
propos de sandro et c'est plus un sujet
de parlement européen plus personne en
parle entre nous d'ailleurs
alors que ça a été pendant un an et demi
un suivi de discussions presque
quotidien presque une overdose du bric
site un moment donné
et les sujets de souveraineté
d'autonomie stratégique qu'il faut
construire aujourd'hui convaincre nos
collègues européens je pense que le
moment est tellement important que
présidentielle en france on pas
présidentielle en france les enjeux
européens de toute façon aurait des
larmes et il aurait fallu les préparer
et les préparer sérieusement et on les
prépare aussi sérieusement s'il y avait
une présidence en france présidentielle
en france on pas ça c'est le premier
élément est ce que ça sera des
défavorables moi je ne pense pas parce
que il ya une forme de prise de risque
dans la présidence française de l'union
européenne puisque on va mettre un
agenda l'agenda politique qui sera connu
et dévoilé au 1er décembre par le
gouvernement français le président de la
république aura à s'exprimer dans
l'hémicycle européen sous forme
d'ailleurs de questions un peu une forme
de questions au gouvernement
auprès des parlementaires européens le
19 janvier
devant l'ensemble de la représentation
européenne et puis avec aussi un élément
symbolique c'est qu'on n'a pas
l'habitude de voir le président de la
république dans cet exercice politique
que sa constitution en france lui
interdit et donc c'est une manière aussi
pour lui de remettre les enjeux sur les
enjeux européens de construire l'agenda
mais aussi de se confronter aux
oppositions européenne et on en connaît
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui en vie les
grands rassemblements et les grandes
coalitions d'extrême droite sont des
éléments dangereux aussi politique de
cette présidence donc moi je dirais la
prise de risque est la même pour nous
l'organisation est la même
il nous manquera du temps peut-être en
terme
puisque vous savez les règles
électorales font que trois mois après le
début de la présidence française on
pourra pas faire d' événement
de conseil est ce qu'on appelle lé
conseil européen
des ministres décentralisé
on en aura de manière décentralisée
pendant les trois premiers mois de la
présidence française de l'union
européenne n'est pas après et après on
reprendra aussi un certain nombre
d'activités puisqu'il faudra de toute
façon et je l'espère enjambées
l'élection présidentielle avec le même
membre du conseil et le même président
de l'union européenne à ce moment-là et
terminait la présidence française avec
d'autres enjeux et puis peut-être un
agenda qui aura glissé et qui sera en
termes d'opportunités différents en tout
cas moi j'ai le sentiment qu'on prend ça
de manière
sérieuse
avec la bonne prise de risque et la
bonne organisation
voilà et que c'est des éléments de
présidentielle à ce stade en tout cas
pour l'organisation européenne ne joue
pas et je trouve que c'est plutôt pas
mal merci stéphane peut-être dire que on
parlait de la défense commune il y aura
un sommet sur la défense européenne qui
se déroulera normalement à toulouse au
mois de mars 2022 ce n'est pas encore
entièrement tranchée mais voilà donc
c'était un début de réponse par rapport
à cette question sur la défense
européenne et pour terminer je pense que
laurence pour nous dire quelques mots
j'ai oublié de vous dit elle est
coordinatrice de la commission culture
mais elle également investi dans la
commission régi celles qui s'occupent
des régions et qui gère notamment les
fonds structurels européens notamment
les fédère le fse florence c'est notre
président à françois bayrou qui m'avait
envoyé dans cette commission justement
pour aller traquer quelques fonds
européens mais oui mais je voudrais
répondre à jean dionis plaisir
d'apercevoir c'est vrai cette question
des fonds européens allaient stratégique
parce qu'en effet ça c'est l'europe
perceptible et qui est connue très
fortement par les élus par les élus de
proximité on sait que c'est un levier
très fort c'est le deuxième budget de de
l'union européenne après la politique
agricole commune donc c'est pas rien je
crois qu'il ya plusieurs sujets
pour faire reconsidérer ces fonds il ya
d'une part le fait de dire ben c'est pas
l'europe tirelire parce que c'est un peu
ça c'est une image qui est donné à
l'europe comme étant une gros coffre
fort et donc se dire déjà ces fonds ils
ont des objectifs ils ont des objectifs
qui sont assignées et qui vont
construire la transition écologique et
le changement et le numérique donc il ya
de la pédagogie à faire au niveau des
élus
deuxième chose l'europe a bon dos sur le
sujet de la complexité parce que
j'en avais qu une campagne régionale il
ya peu de temps et je ne dois pas être
les seuls ici on sait très bien que
c'est aussi le nerf de la guerre pour
les régions et on a eu des débats sur ce
point sur aussi la possibilité de
décomplexifier de dire il ya d'autres
oui les régions sont les organismes
gestionnaires mais elles ne doivent pas
voir tout pouvoir on doit pouvoir
territorialisée c'était une demande dans
notre département des pyrénées
atlantiques par l par exemple d'avoir
des défend délégué aux communautés
d'agglomération ça a été non parce que
l'argent c'est le pouvoir donc je crois
que l'europe a bon dos il faut vraiment
que nous on fasse pression et on
continue sur les exécutifs régionaux et
puis que quand il c'est vrai que la
présidence française doit s'emparer de
ce sujet mais je crois que au travers de
jacqueline gourault on est très bien
placé pour discuter des sujets des fonds
et de la dea complexification des fonds
mais aussi laurence dont on peut encore
dire que dans le cas d'autres éléphants
de la relance 100 milliards d'euros en
france pour le plan de relance national
40 milliards qui viennent de l'union
européenne et dites le autour de vous
répéter le ces hyper important ces 40
milliards ne coûte pas un centime à aux
côteries bleus français rien ne sort de
la poche du contribuable français car
c'est financé par des fonds propres
européen donc la france gagne également
des subventions et de l'argent avec ce
système de plans de relance européens
alors nous allons prendre encore trois
questions
oui je t'avais pas identifié philippe tu
veux
alors il nous reste 5 minutes en fait
hein donc on va essayer d'être
conciliant il y a une très belle table
ronde sur l'égalité des chances juste
après et donc je voudrais surtout pas
prendre sur le temps de travail on va
regarder comment fonctionner
bonjour je suis dans l'eure alors ma
question je veux faire très rapidement
sur la formation et sur la recherche
scientifique c'est vrai on discutait
avec une collègue je pense à ce niveau
là au niveau européen et français ont
loupé le coche sur plein de choses la
première chose ça devait en recevoir au
niveau européen je pense qu'il ya une
bonne gueule une bonne collaboration à
ce niveau là pour récupérer nos
étudiants à l'échelle européenne et
deuxième chose puisqu'on a une vision de
technicité vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure je pense c'était monsieur
s'était fait à ces journées je sais pas
celui qui au milieu sur la triptyque sur
la technique et
non je me suis trompé non non ça va très
bien alors sur le triptyque est donc
pour être à la pointe de la technicité
il faut avoir un visu sur la rive sud
s'avère sur l'afrique on a plein de gens
qui arrivent formé avec des maîtrises
war plus il faut en leur classe ici
c'était mon cas et donc après de longues
années de recherches dès qu'ils sont
formés qui sont prêts pour être
productifs ils partent à l'étranger ça
vers les états unis ailleurs je trouve
que sur ce point là on n'est pas au
point ça veut dire on laisse beaucoup de
nous énergie partir ailleurs et une
deuxième en deuxième lieu et ce il faut
aussi qu'on fasse un travail sûr
sur l'alternance et sur la formation de
nos jeunes et ce qu'elle a dit madame
laurence fink à ce niveau là qui à nos
collectivités
l'europe aussi prendre nos jeunes sur
différentes niveaux je regarde les
derniers points sur les mairies il peut
faire de l'espace vert mais ils peuvent
aller jusqu'à la finance merci bien
merci bien alors il ya encore 2 qui sera
il ya plein de questions je veux
simplement vous dire que on a des
ateliers europe organisé par le p2 en
parallèle enfin toute la journée demain
également on est présent un peu partout
donc on pourra également répondre à vos
questions tout au long de la journée
philippe tu veux nous apprend ici alors
non à huy aucun doute au fond
viviane boussier yvelines ma question
est un peu à nax par rapport au titre de
cette table ronde vous avez évoqué deux
fois le mot eux il est inscrit en
gros sur le comme premier lot beau ici
or je commence comment se fait-il que
l'on est en tant qu'adhérent aucune
nouvelle du pds aux fall est strictement
sur le s'inscrire à la newsletter
mais il n'y a aucune communication
officielle vous fait pourtant des choses
qui sont formidables où en est-on
vis-à-vis des adhérents de terrain pour
adhérer au pge pourquoi la cob est elle
aussi mauvaise autrement dit en deux
trois mots un petit topo sur le pdo
merci davance merci est donc au coeur
alors en fait je ne distribue pas la
parole c'est ceux qui ont le micro que
donc on entend des bruits en deux
minutes comme à l'assemblée je reviens
sur sur l'idée de sandro sur 7 euros
dépensés pour la défense euros dépensés
pour la culture et en profiter pour
rendre hommage à nos amis qui nous a
quittés l'an dernier c'est philippe
daverio parce que philippe qui était un
écrivain à succès en italie qui était un
français un écrivain à succès en italie
vous le savez et ai milité pour cette
europe de la culture et il avait ce mot
sublime de dire que lorsque nous aurons
fait l'europe de la culture la grèce
pourra vivre de droits d'auteur et cet
objectif nous devons l'atteindre
pourquoi parce que militairement quand
nous réussissons des objectifs je prends
l'exemple du sel nous sommes
complètement absents d'un point de vue
culturel qui va dans le cercle de la
massina pour rappeler qu'il y avait un
des écrivains en langue française les
plus sublimes que nous ayons jamais eu
''c'était amadou hampate ba qui c'est
qui va réexaminer tous ses écrits et
aller chercher dans ces peuples que nous
libérons d'une oppression le fait de se
reconstruire par la culture personne ne
le fait aujourd'hui nous avons des
succès militaires nous sommes absents
culturellement c'est pour ça que cette
idée de sandro il faut à tout prix que
nous là cultivions un euro pour la
défense un euro pour la culture merci
bien très bien merci philippe alors il
ya une réponse rapide aux deux questions
laurent on va commencer par frédéric sur
le petit le pve ou sur eux voilà un
petit éclairage de gens lui on va
essayer d'être dans la synthèse et sur
l'apprentissage juste une remarque on a
comme ça fait partie des lois qu'il faut
que vous défendez sur le terrain la loi
sur l'apprentissage la loi sur
l'apprentissage un volet celle qu'on a
réussi qui a fait exploser
l'apprentissage en france c'est une loi
qui a également
internationalisé notre apprentissage
mois au moment du au moment du et qui a
très vite marché au moment du coc vide
en pologne il a fallu qu'on rapatrie ou
qu'on se pose des questions pour
quatorze apprentis france et en pologne
et je crois que cette notion là relisez
la moi j'étais ou adressez vous à moi on
peut aujourd'hui de manière beaucoup
plus simple internationalisé au niveau
européen internationalisé les parcours
d'apprentissage y compris avant le bac
et y compris sur les métiers des pme
merci j'ai juste quand celle sur le
sujet d'autant que c'est maintenant
totalement inclus au programme erasmus
plus mobilité longue des apprentis fait
le saas est l'objet d'un travail de
précédents mais c'est intégré
aujourd'hui donc c'est là et il ya des
combats à voir maintenant c'est vraiment
sur les entreprises et sur la
simplification des parcours
d'apprentissage parce qu'on sait que
c'est il reste des difficultés pour les
jeunes d'où le travail qu'on fait sur
l'espace repas de l'éducation sur une
nécessaire harmonisation des formations
sachant que c'est très complexe dans le
domaine de l'apprentissage mais au moins
comment on sanctuary ce statut de
l'apprenti en mobilité et c'est
aujourd'hui dans le programme erasmus
mais sait il faut essuyer les plâtres et
il faut défricher merci lisandro un mot
sur le p2 quand même à merci à paris
chez merci beaucoup pour l'encouragement
j'apprécie beaucoup maintenant on a on
est rentré dans une nouvelle phase et le
bon sort comme nous tous d'une
période des périodes difficiles
notamment liés de la pandémie mais aussi
à des événements qui vous connaissez
vous connaissez très bien qu'on a déjà
évoqué
avec
avec la nouvelle équipe très triquet et
secrétaire adjoint avec nos députés
européens nous allons nous concentrer
sur deux grandes initiatives des grandes
opérations je dirais pour les douze mois
qui est 100 devant nous la première
c'est évidemment profiter au maximum de
la conférence l'avenir de l'europe pour
aller sur le terrain et pour alimenter
animer des débats participe pas
participé avec des débats citoyens sur
l'avenir de l'europe en parallèle à la
conférence dont on a parlé est la
deuxième des travailler sur ce que nous
appelons les robes des solutions
l'europe pas seulement la solution
européenne mais les solutions concrètes
que l'europe apporte pour nos
agriculteurs pour notre jeunesse pour
notre industrie ces terrains est
évidemment celle ci devra accompagner
par un grand effort de communication de
tous les partis nationaux affiliés au
parti démocrate européen donc moi je
compte beaucoup sur vous et moi je
compte beaucoup saura les modèles pour
ses concerts la france merci sans gros
et le mot de la fin pour aujourd'hui
bourlanges qui vous feront un petit
commentaire oui je voudrais faire un
petit commentaire à leur rapide sur le
le rapport culture défense qui a été mis
en en avant par par sandro est repris
par vous je crois qu'effectivement le
l'un des grands enjeux c'est de sortir
de l'europe des bisounours
l'europe des bisounours et c'est très
bien c'est l'europe du droit ça doit pas
exclure l'europe de la force je ne dis
pas la violence jeudi de la force
l'europe des bisounours et l'europe de
l'exemplarité nous devons être bons
sannois ps sur l'europe de la
réciprocité nous devons obtenir de nos
concurrents deux des autres qui s'aligne
sur qui fasse des efforts
eh ben on le compare à bonhôte l'europe
des bisounours et l'europe de
l'universalité nous faisons comme
emmanuel quand nous agissons
sur zouzou ce qui est bien
universellement l'europe réel c'est
l'europe des particularités il y a une
particularité européenne qui est défié
par le monde donc on a ce grand
changement ça veut pas dire abandonner
les valeurs mais ça veut dire combiné
c'est là le propre de la politique
max weber disait que la politique
c'était un va et vient entre les valeurs
et la réalité
l'europe avait tendance à ignorer la
réalité et l'europe d'avant elle avait
tendance à ignorer les valeurs pendant
l'entre-deux-guerres et pendant la
période horrible du bolchevisme là nous
devons tenir sa et les européens mais
s'il cesse des bisounours vont pas
devenir du jour au lendemain et au
niveau de l'union européenne des gros
durs c'est pas vrai la violence la
politique militaire etc ça va être très
difficile parce que c'est l'otan s'est
pas l'europe parce que il ya une culture
pacifique extrêmement extrêmement
développé nous avons des habitudes de
chats domestiques un chat domestique
c'est pas un titre le remettre en
liberté
ça suffit pas il aime bien il a été
protégé par les américains donc il faut
trouver c'est ça que je veux dire il
faut trouver le juste niveau pour
l'europe pour passer franchir cette
métamorphose et je crois que ça consiste
à passer effectivement pas seulement par
la culture mais d'une façon générale par
le cognitif je crois que nous devons
mettre de la puissance de la concurrence
géopolitique dans notre révolution
cognitive et nous devons mettre du
cognitif dans notre révolution de la
puissante c'est la technologie c'est la
recherche c'est la formation c'est notre
capacité à inventer le monde de demain
qui nous permettra aussi de réaliser
ce que n'ont pas l'europe puissance mais
une europe puissante je crois qu'il faut
bien définir cette affaire là c'est là
aussi tu la révolution copernicienne
il faut effectivement savoir que nous
sommes dans un monde de compétition où
nos valeurs sont attaque t elle ne se
sont pas imposés comme on le pensait il
ya au moment de la chute du mur de
berlin fukuyama et c'est l'idée de la
femme d'histoire c'est faux nous avons
bien vu que nos valeurs européennes sont
concurrencés et qu'elle mérite d'être
défendue donc nous sommes bien dans une
épreuve mais cette épreuve l'union
européenne son rôle principal pas
exclusif à aussi fiable à du militaire
mais son rôle principal ce sera de nous
mener de réelles réussir cette
révolution cognitive dont nous avons
proclamé il ya 21 ans à lisbonne au
conseil européen de lisbonne l'urgence
et l'impératif et nous avons
tragiquement échoué dans ce domaine nous
avons perdu au cours des vingt dernières
années des parts de marché des avancées
et c'est là où nous devons retrouver le
chemin c'est la vraie dimension
européenne de la puissance merci jean
louis là où il ya une volonté il ya un
chemin vers 6 à tous vous la qualité des
échanges et sans plus tarder j'appelle
sylvain waserman à nous rejoindre pour
une très très intéressant de table ronde
à laquelle je vous invite tous à
participer sur l'égalité des chances
merci